so can you hear me in the back awesome
let's start so my name is Yvonne Berlin
and today we're going to talk about this
new paradigm in NLP called self
attention so actually like a couple of
months ago I saw this blog post by
Eugenio cooler cello and he writes drop
the iron and drop the Alice T on don't
use those anymore you don't need that
you only need attention attention is all
you need right and when I read this I
was like what the like we did this for
three or five years and we were so
successful and are we just supposed to
throw it away so in this talk I'm going
to answer this question like can we
actually skip the whole part and just
use attention so let's take a quick step
back I currently studying computational
mystics at the LMU also studying
technology management at the same time
I'm doing a lot of research mainly in
relation extraction also profiling also
obfuscation and stuff like that if
you're interested in any of those come
up to me later and I also work as a
part-time data engineer at trust you so
just very quickly a trustee we do
automated summarization we collect a lot
of readings from the internet and then
for each hotel in the world based on the
reviews they get we output like one
sentence summary like four six hundred
thousand four thousand okay so let's
jump right in first let's take a look at
how the sort of neural NLP has developed
so we all started with our and ends in
an RN am you get the sick sequence a
sentence and then you just go from the
first one to last and encode information
in the end it sort of outputs an encoder
there just like a sentence and bedding
but there are nouns that really worked
it well well they are a bit more complex
than that but there is a problem of like
the gradients not rocket not propagating
properly you're losing a lot of
information so that's why people came up
with long short term memory and gated
recurrent units so basically it's an
improvement or RNN
which just adds up more logic that helps
the model decide whether the input is
important or not and should i propagate
it to the next step so they use sort of
something called gating mechanisms and
this is the whole logic that's in there
well people also use CNN for NLP well
when I first started this was really
geared for me like how can you see an
answer NLP well the best way to think
about this is in the image you have
pixels and then you have sort of height
and but you actually and then if you
like max pooling and stuff like that or
that well actually you have the same
thing in sentences because your height
is like the number of words in the
sentence
and the width is the dimensionality of
the embedding of word to vacuum reading
for example so that's how can you use
CNN's right and L STM's are often used
in an architecture that we call in
quarterly core or sequence to sequence
especially this is used in neural
machine translation where you like input
a sentence in German and then it will
output a sentence in English right and
this looks kind of like this so the red
part is the encoder
you can use lsdm GRU with everyone and
somehow you encode the sentence and
create a vector z that this sort of like
a sentence and bedding and then you give
the sentence embedding to your decoder
model which can also be an ALICE TM but
doesn't how to and then it will sort of
translate it so this is a really nice
example where it's translating an idiom
from German xdk Kista it's actually
translated correctly in English and says
it's awesomesauce
right but so LSD ants were kind of
created to deal with this vanishing
reading problem so the information not
propagating and sort of LSD answer are
supposed to fix this but this is a
sentence this is like I don't know 50
yards long this is from Ward and Pete
Warren peace by Leo Tolstoy and like
he's supposed to use an Alice TM for
that it's not really going to work so
what's the solution here we
- on - attention mechanisms you can use
the tension to improve LST ancestry
let's see enhance either for NLP or for
image recognition so let's first start
with understanding images this is a
model from deep mind and it sort of hops
over the image but only attends to the
most important part
so here it's classifying like house
numbers and you see it doesn't scan the
whole image it only scans the part that
has a number in there
well actually it's very similar in Aldie
when you read the text
you often skim through it you don't
really read the whole thing all the time
and maybe only some part of it are
important some are not so this is a sort
of model that uses LST answers attention
to do summarization of restaurant
reviews and beauty salon reviews and you
can see the red part is factually where
the model is paying the most attention
so it's saying like this is a nice place
my favorite restaurant food is
incredible and so on so the model is
actually selecting the stuff that's
important for the summarization right
and you can also use this attention in
the encoder/decoder model when use from
sliding from one language to another you
see that the width of those lines
actually show you how much attention the
the words you going to translate is
paying to other words in the sentence so
that the bigger it is the more attention
it tasted right it's a bit more complex
than that there are a lot of formulas
but when you deal with attention you can
either use it for translation but you
can also actually use it for simple
document classification like you can
just create an attention or rewards to
build the sentence embedding and then
over that you can build sort of document
embedding based on the sentences and you
will only attend to the sentences that
actually should like contribute elect to
your classification so I'm not going to
go over the formulas but when you deal
with attentions
most of the time they look like this so
the first part the you is the context
director and that there are many ways
how you can do this so there's no
standard way for attention that is why
like in fight or stands or flow there is
no layer called attention you just have
other stands in their hands because
there are so many of them but the the
like the next part is almost always the
same you just do like a soft neck
separation to get the probability and
then use those probabilities to improve
your lsdm or whatever you using right so
actually this helps a lot on the left
side you see in neural machine
translation we use a blue score to say
how accurate the translation is and if
the sentence is has more words has more
than 40 words then it sort of goes down
but on the right side where you have a
tension that sort of stays stable even
if sentences are really long like six
years so anymore so that works quite
well well actually it also helps you to
see what the model is learning what's
it's attending to so you can look at
those weights what words are
contributing to other ones so you can
look at individual words say this from
French to English this word insult it's
translated and it looks to economic area
or whatnot and then you do another one
and sort of you can also debug your
model this way but also sort of
visualize it right so we saw we can use
attention to rural Siam's
but it's also possible to skip the whole
lsdm CNN part and use attention so this
was first done by Google brain they
published the paper in July 2017 so a
year ago where they don't have any
convolution nor recurrence
it's just layers of attention and sort
of very high-level overview it just
takes one word and then from
to all the other words and tries to get
the similarity and it's like a set
operation
it doesn't care where the word is so
just compares everything to everything
and based on that it encodes this
information passes it to the decoder
then the caller can also attend to like
separate words right so simple it's
actually quite complicated but we'll try
to figure it out at least on a more high
level so on the left side you have the
encoder and the right is the decoder
basically there are only few like
specific layers in there that I then
just repeated or used in like different
constellation so we start with our
sentence which is encoded in words back
over there and I told you it's a set
operation right so it's like the model
doesn't know where the word sub position
so they also actually had this very
interesting idea of instead of passing
like indices of words where the words
are situated in the sentence they use
wavelength functions to generate a wave
that will then show where the word is in
the sentence I'm going to show you more
example and that just keep that in mind
after that you have this block the whole
encoder and in the encoder first you
have multi-head attention which is like
actually the soul of the whole
architecture this is the self attention
itself so we're going to look into that
in more detail but let's talk on the
like let's see what it is on the higher
level you have also residual connections
you probably know that from like imaging
algorithms where you where you do
something with the inputs you don't want
to lose too much information so in the
beginning you make a copy of it and then
add it up add that copy to your outfit
later that you sort of still give that
information then in the end after the
soul multi-head attention they have a
sort of four feed-forward network that
is trying to figure out what the
attention was outputting so it's very
simple like using activation function
weights and biases and in the end
you have to somehow sorry to somehow to
normalize the output so you've probably
heard about batch normalization or LAN
organization so the authors here using
layer normalization for neural machine
translation for them it works quite well
right and then it'd be color is sort of
almost the same it's just structured a
bit differently an important part now
you you can also have like multiple
layers so the in color can be like six
layers it's the same that you would do
with Ellis TMS you can also he'll like
multiple layers of fellows TM and then
the multi head attention it's also like
copied but into that very soon so I told
you about the positional encodings in
the form of a wavelength so basically
the authors say hey I'm gonna give I'm
gonna have this function where I give
the index position of the world and then
I do some like maths magic with some
constants and in the end I'm gonna get a
wavelength so it can easily be easily
visualized like this but this is another
visualization of that so you can see
there like this is word number in the
zero word one two three and so on and
then for each position in a sentence
it's kind of generating those things and
actually the the authors say doesn't
really make that much difference what
they do here you can just use like
typical positional embeddings but
there's one difference when you like
during your training you see only
sentences that are up to lengths 60
words so when you're predicting and the
sentences are longer than the 60 words
and you're just using like learn
positional embeddings they're not going
to work because your model has never
actually seen word at position 61 or 62
because that wasn't present in the
training model so but but here if you
use this function you just say hey
here's position 62 generating this
wavelength so this can actually help the
model
war it was even longer sentences right
but this is very absolute so it's just
encoding it for one position then there
was like a follow-up research by the
same authors basically they say hey we
can have relative positional embedding
so let's look at the context but see
maybe they have a window towards before
the word I'm looking at towards after
that word and then I'll try to also get
the context
how are the embedding looking for that
word yeah so actually at the LMU in my
university we had this idea as well even
before the paper was published but we
have a sort of different implementation
we also use relative embeddings but
instead of having a window that sort of
moves we use something called positional
Benning so let's say next word is very
important to me the word after that it
is also important but words like three
four five they're not so important so
let's bend them up in one class sort of
and they all get the same weights and
then if they are even longer far away
then make the bin even bigger so yeah
well the attention the multi had
attention the sort of soul of the the
architecture is actually very simple and
I'm going to explain everything so it
uses this idea that you can use Curie's
to extract some values and the curie is
your word encoding and then you somehow
create those two matrices keys that you
can do similarity ways and then valleys
so I showed you I told you in the
beginning I take one word and then just
try to look how similar are other words
in the sentence to the word I'm looking
at now and in order to do this
efficiently and fast you have to have
these separate matrices to do that so
let's go over an example say I have the
sentence right it's from word one and
the word end
and my words are encoded with were to
act over terror so in the original model
they have 512 dimensions and then you do
the positional staff that we talked
about you just add them up so you sort
of also add this information where the
words are situated in the sentence and
then let's say okay let's look at one
word word at position x2 I want to see
how similar are other words to that one
so I use something called compatibility
function and I say at position to look
at position one look at position three
and four and so on and let's get let's
find out how similar they are and you
can do this by using this trick with
like key matrices and in the end it's
track the similar rods using the value
matrices so if I do this for position
two and one I get some sort of
similarity maybe this word is a bit
similar when I compare it to itself of
course it's the most similar because the
word in the sentence is more similar to
itself and then let's say for example
the word three is even more similar to
that in the word one word for is even
more so that means hey I need to pay
attention to this word for when I'm
looking at word two because somehow it's
similar and you do do this for the whole
sentence and now you have to somehow use
it so you can run a softmax operation
basically softmax will give you a
probability distribution over all of
those similarities that you had just
computed and now you can use this
probability to to create this top level
Z vector it's like we saw in the encoder
lsdm creates those D vectors that are
sort of like a sentence embedding and
here you're basically doing the same
thing but you're not using recurrence or
anything else you just using this
attention mechanism with similarity
right and then you do this trick where
you multiply the similarity probability
with this other matrix of values and and
then this is how you encoding in the end
looks like right and
you do this couple of times basically
you multiply your heads and you have
different heads and actually they are in
the beginning the same but all of them
have different weights so they learn
something else each of them learn
something else so the head on the last
sort of here you can see it looks very
closely to the words next to it and the
word under the head on the right it kind
of attends to words that are further
away right so it's sort of learning
something from there and then there are
also other examples where somehow
figures out like reference what are
words referring to like if I have the
animal crossed the street because it was
two tires or didn't cross the street and
then the it it was too tired the head
can actually figure out what it is
referring to is it referring to animal
or to the street so yeah and then when
you try to reimplemented of yourself
you've just gone fail because there are
so many details it's just ridiculous a
lot of constants lots of stuff
one example is you can't really train it
the usual way you have to do learning
rate warm-up which means you start with
learning rate zero and then you increase
it gradually over like four thousand
epochs and after epoch four thousand you
you serve decades and for some reason
this works better when you're doing like
neural machine translation and then this
model is trainings like three hundred
thousand epochs but that's probably
because it's Google right they have tons
of data so they didn't need more time
right so don't do this from scratch
there is an official library from Google
created in tensorflow
there are also other ones in Amex net in
pi torch and you can also find like
really nice blocks to try to lower the
code and explain how it is sort of
implemented right so we saw salsa
dancing can be used for neural machine
translation but there are actually other
applications
again Google drain they used it for
something else they tried to quickly
summarize text like based on Wikipedia
articles and then they can also generate
new Wikipedia articles like fake ones
and they had an example where the model
generates and Wikipedia article a
voltage of a nice metal band was like
Japanese names and cities and whatever
and it looks so real it's actually
totally fake
the model has learned to sort of create
those texts itself then we at our
University
a team of researchers used it for like
relation argument extraction so we're
going to come back to that in a bit then
there's some research by Berkeley
University they use sulphate engine
color to improve constituency parsing
and they are actually beating the
state-of-the-art which I think was
previously like Alice TM based and then
right now there's a lot of research
going on into South attention by open AI
they saying hey we train this like task
agnostic language models that can do
lots of stuff like question answering a
textual payment reasoning and it's all
based on sort of self attention this is
there is a preprint it's not published
they're still working on it but it's
really cool and you can see the dates
it's like everything is like super new
this all happened in 2018 so this area
of research is like really new but also
very exciting so just quick note Google
is not the only one doing this there is
also another self attention model which
is called this an like directional self
attention we're going to talk about that
because that would need like a nice
representation but just so you know
there are like other options to do this
ok so now I want to introduce our
research from the LMU we actually used
self attention encoders to do a relation
specification and this is done together
with Benjamin rod he's a professor of
computational mystics
LMU and we basically worked on this for
the last half a year or something so
what is a relation extraction let's
first have a couple of examples so in
relation extraction you try to extract
some information from sentences you have
two entities in the sentence and then
you try to find hey what is the relation
between those entities for example a
relation person employee of you will
find figure out hey does this person ex
work for a company why over terror and I
have an example for that for example
sentence go AIG intends to sell shares
in American Life Insurance Co blah blah
blah said form in your shadow a
tokyo-based spokesman for AIG
so you have two entities one is for me
Ashley Sato the other one is AIG and
then you tell hey look into this and
what is the relation here what is there
is a relation in this sentence between
Fumio she Sato and a AG and then the
model looks at the sentence and based on
the what the sentence has like all the
other context words it decides what
relation it is so yeah and why you need
a relation extraction basically you use
it in in many ways first you can create
like knowledge database isn't ologies
you can use it in question answering
summarization it's this technique is
even used in biology to like find
protein interactions and like there are
many use cases for this so before we had
like neural NLP we had this feature
based approach it did some parsing and
soft and it has rules and it one of the
rules is hey there look if there exists
some dependency tree that is not longer
than two words and what's not so this
was like state of the art until 2015 and
then came along some neural models we
used CNN's we used Alice TMS and they
improved a lot the state of the art and
the sort of this final state of the art
and up until now who was from Stanford
Stanford
P they had this idea to use an Alice TM
with attention but they improve
attention they call it position a very
attention so actually I told you the in
relation extraction you have two
entities and what they do is they encode
separate positional embeddings for those
entities so they say oh my my first
ended year is at position 5 so let's
create like an embedding for that and my
another entity is somewhere in the end
of the sentence so I have a different
positional embedding for that right and
then they use Alice TM and I told you
like you're going to see this formula a
lot because that's basically how you do
attention and as I've told you they sort
of have their own idea of how to create
this context factor and the rest is the
same
and also they didn't just create the
model they also create a really nice
data set it's quite huge it's 120,000
examples and it actually has 42 relation
classes which is a lot and it's relation
classes like for persons and for
organisations and one thing is this data
set is very complex because 80% of it is
like examples where there is no relation
let's say you have a sentence Mike is
working as a I don't know a teacher
there is a relation that mark is a
teacher but if you have a sentence mike
is not a teacher then there is no
relation like it's indication so you
know the model has to also figure this
out
or if you have a sentence Jane likes to
travel around the u.s. is there a
relation between Jane in the u.s. maybe
there is some but it's not important to
our database like you're not building
facts about where Jane likes to travel
to so there is no relation in in our
model and they there so that they get
like 65.1 F score which is quite high
considering you have 40 do classes and
the sentences are really long like the
average sentence length is 40 words and
the longest one is like 96
which is quite a lot so yeah and then we
implement a new model we use self
attention plus we use this part of
position of our attention so we in the
end combine them first let's look at
self attention encoder this is what we
had before that's what I try to explain
to you and then then this is our
modification of that so we change lots
of stuff I told you we have our own
implementation of like relative
embeddings and then we don't have to
residual connections we only have one
because we saw this works much better
for the task of realizing extraction
then we also even changed like
activation functions we found out that
Varallo is not working so well here
random rallo is much better also layer
normalization doesn't work we tried like
different techniques and so ok batch
normalization is working much better
then we changed a lot of stuff maybe the
most important one is that we don't have
to train for like three hundred thousand
epochs the model actually converges in
just 60 maybe it's just because less
data maybe it's just two tasks but it's
just taking like one or two to get
really good results so how do we combine
that I told you hey this part is sort of
generated by an LS TM so let's just take
that away and plug in our output of the
self attention encoder so we give this Q
vector or Z vector and then we also
change this other thing they say they
also want like a final output of the LS
TM which is like the final sentence
encoding and you say okay we can also
provide that
we just do like a max pooling layer of
ourselves encoder output and hey we are
completely replacing LST amps in this
case so this model is attention only it
has self attention and then on top it's
using position of our intention created
by Stanford so yeah what are the results
if you compare that we are getting
better results well not that much better
just
point five percent in general if you're
using one model but still they're like
we are the new state of the art
basically at least based on that data
set what also Stanford and he did is
they also had an insane bling model so
they tried five models with different
random seats and then did majority
warding over that over that and we do
the same thing and for some reason the
in sampling doesn't really work that
well we are like 0.1% there which is
yeah not so much
but still a bit there right so this this
was all done in Python and Python
obviously so yeah I've been working for
this on this for the last half a year
and I really like fighters coming from
Tiano or tensorflow
really like programming in Python so
yeah I guess it's about it
get in touch unfortunately though our
research is not published yet we are
still working on it but we will probably
have a preprint next week or in two
weeks on archive and I hope in August
we'll release the source code so that
Aaron can use it yeah I get lots of
references take a look at those thank
you for your attention that's not the
time
thanks very much even for a really nice
talk are there any questions in the
audience
yeah hi thank you for the talk I have a
question about memory consumption of the
model as we can see like for example in
the hierarchical attention models you
basically compare every time with a
context vector and here you store
matrices with like similarity from all
of the words to the all of the words how
extensive extensive lists for memory if
you're using if you don't have that much
power as you as Google heads yeah you do
use up more memory but it's much faster
because it's parallelized so each head
from this multi hat attention can be
calculated in parallel you do get like
you need more memory but for the example
we did versus a relation extraction it
was okay like I had a GPU that six
gigabytes vram and we still was fine
like you don't need a I don't know v 100
over there okay thank you
sure
yeah thanks very much for the
interesting talk one question on the
latest research you did and presented
today how did you come up with the
changes you made to the architecture
your you are a new models based on yes
so some of it was based on previous
research from our University but the
rest was many times trying out things
it's like you know deep learning is
basically trying out stuff and maybe
it'll work and I had half a year for
that so yeah in the end so in in the
paper we're going to publish I try to
like explain everything that we tried so
then you don't have to do it again so
wait for that there's everything
explained but this actually was a lot of
trial and error but in the end the
results are pretty good sure any more
questions
somewhere so I I have one one related
question so do you actually do a proper
feature ablation study when you kind of
like you did a lot of changes so do you
actually explore which part of the
change of the architecture is getting
you an improvement of how many percent
on that dataset yeah actually we do
again it will be in the paper so I have
like the table comparing all the results
and we also try to visualize the models
like I showed you you can visualize
attention and you can do the same thing
with self attention so we go or some
sentence examples and try to see hey
what's changing and what's better so we
actually like debugging it
sentence-by-sentence sometimes to figure
out hey does this actually work
what was the most important architecture
change
I think the residual connections like if
you only have one and then fetch
normalization was huge impact and
actually also using this position
attention layer from Stanford helps a
lot because if you only use self
attention encoder which you can do
actually there is also like half of the
state of the art so you actually need
this additional attend
mayor for that okay thank you any any
other questions we have plenty of time
for two over there I was just wondering
why we use cosine and sinusoidal
functions like for 40 positions like I I
didn't get this part too well
yeah I think it was just a gimmick for
the taper like to make it look cool
well yes but actually they actually say
in the paper hey you can just use like
typical positional embeddings and there
is also the same right but I told you
there's one difference right if you
train a model that only sees short
sentences when you do like typical
positional embeddings it can't learn
anything about the positions that are
like over the ones that you saw but if
you just run this like over cosine and
sine function it will actually give you
a wavelength so you kind of can learn
something from that so that it's like
the biggest difference I see they're
waving it's like like do you do any
transformations on this functions later
on to guess yeah they like dividing by
some constants and stuff and the
constants are just again I think trial
and error from from the authors of the
paper they just tried so many things and
say okay this works right maybe they
have some explanation for those but it's
hard to like find the paper is like
really short great Hawke Thanks thank
you I think is attention really all you
need is we're going to replace the
intense and SVM's
I think so especially not just based on
our research but I told you open the
eyes work in this they have like really
really promising results and they
haven't like fully published yet so I'm
hoping they will bring out
something really cool and then maybe we
don't really need to use it lsdm say
thank you very much more questions or
yep I have one more question how can I
deal with the what texts of different
lengths for example I have I don't know
comments which are like 200 words and
also the others who are like only five
words links yeah because it the
attention the whole point of attention
is that you you look like that word 200
but you always have this reference
vector with all attention so you can
just look back and see based on the
probability distribution what are the
most similar words to the one I'm
looking at so I can actually maybe the
word one is more similar right and and
this for example the difference between
German and English is in in German you
have works like in the end of the
sentence
so the lsdm wouldn't really work that
well so you need like by lsdm that goes
both ways but here you don't need that
because like it's always even
distribution and you always know what
you tend to thank you very much so let's
thank you one again for a really nice
talk
[Applause]